he's talking about an international
bailout ladies and gentlemen joining me
now is victor davis hanson hoover
institution senior fellow now victor
walt disney made sure disneyland was a
success before he launched disney world
biden's buildback better plan went up in
flames at home now he wants to explore
to support it to the rest of the world
how does this make any sense victor
it doesn't raymond it's sort of the new
green deal on steroids and obama's
apology tour and the davos globalism all
in one i mean the premise is we
exploited these countries by buying
their natural resources so we owe it to
them if you read what he said a year
almost a year ago in june when he first
floated the idea right and we owe it you
know to and the the obvious question is
okay well let's develop the oil we have
at home and the precious
metals and minerals and the timber that
we're not using and we can do it more
ecologically sound than anybody in the
world people of
north dakota texas alaska they're
geniuses let's use them or and then you
know we're printing 2 trillion dollars
so the idea is that let's print some
more money for people overseas that are
dysfunctional societies and let's not
spend it here at home
and then you think
okay
victor yeah we looked into this thing i
mean it's gimmick of the week they have
a rendezvous with the disaster in
november and one day it's putin did it
and then the next day let's cancel all
student debt and now let's let's build
back as you said build back the world
better because we tried it at home and
nobody wanted it maybe these guys are
not so smart as we are we looked into
this victor this build back better world
initiative was something the white house
agreed to in june of 2021 it's it's
global leaders pledging to satisfy
the infrastructure needs of these low to
middle income countries they claim that
a 40-plus trillion dollar infrastructure
need is in the developing world and we
the united states is supposed to fill
the gap how is this possible victor
it's not that's why we have 11 and a
half percent inflation
wholesale price inflation because we're
printing money that we don't have and
it's bad enough when we're doing it to
give to americans and now we're going to
give it to other people and to justify
it we're going to make us feel guilty
that somehow
sometime somewhere we exploited them so
we owe it to them to build their
infrastructure which they can't do i got
a better idea why not just send them all
over here and follow a timber guy in
alaska or a fracker in
texas and they can show you how to
develop resources very environmentally
sound or a trucker in alabama we've got
all the talent here bring people over on
an interim program and they can see how
to develop their infrastructure and
their natural resources efficiently and
environmentally correct
build mentorship back better world
initiative
biden seems pretty confident though
victor about our global standing watch
this
the united states is in the position to
out-compete i'll compete the world once
again
we have an incredible opportunity ahead
of us
we still face tremendous challenges
but if we can keep coming together
there's simply no limit i mean no limit
is what we can achieve
victor we have the highest inflation in
40 years we're broke but biden wants us
to spend money internationally on and
i'm going to read from the build back
better world initiative climate health
health security and gender equality on a
global scale how is this possible
you know what it is raymond this is the
civilian version of the disaster in
afghanistan we turned over a billion
dollar embassy 400 million dollar
refitted besp air base in central asia
and 70 billion dollars of weapons and we
couldn't do anything but we did have the
pride flag and with the george floyd
murals and gender studies at the
university of kabul and so that's what
it's all about this this narrative woke
narrative not backed by any reality or
any competence or any wisdom and so it's
pathetic and i they have a rendezvous
with a reckoning everybody that's
watching us uh you raymond tonight knows
it's coming and biden knows best of all
what he's done they had the congress had
the presidency they had everything all
the institutions and they gave us
hardcore socialism and they're going to
pay for it and they're coming up with
gimmicks and it's pathetic
well victor i i thank you for your
insight tonight no one else reported on
this buildback better world initiative
or our opening story i thank you for
putting it in context have a wonderful
easter hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else